these are three contenders the
government's secured
agreements with all very different
vaccines
the oxford university astrozenica
vaccine takes the dna
that contains the code for the spike
protein that causes covid19
and adds it to a harmless chimpanzee
virus that's been genetically engineered
so it can't harm humans
the hope is the body recognizes the
protein
and develops an immune response
producing both neutralizing antibodies
which disable the virus
and t cells a type of white blood cell
which
kill infected cells both of which help
prevent infection
today we've heard in early trials the
vaccine does just this
and importantly that it's safe the bio
n-tech
fisa trial is an mrna vaccine a new
technology it uses
synthetic strands of mrna genetic code
which mimic the virus once injected they
instruct the body's cells to make the
proteins needed to fight the virus
initial results have shown that all
volunteers from phase 1 and phase 2
trials have produced antibodies
but it's completely new as yet there are
no mrna vaccines
that have been approved for use the last
candidate is being developed by the
french company
val neva it's an inactivated vaccine a
much more
traditional technique it takes the virus
and makes it inactive and this causes an
immune response but there are questions
about how long and how strong protection
would be
and this vaccine is at a much earlier
stage clinical trials
haven't started yet the government has
potential access
to millions of doses of each of the
vaccines but they're not the only
vaccines being developed
globally 23 are already in clinical
trials and experts say
it's important the uk has a foothold in
several different vaccine approaches the
government needs to back lots of
different horses on this one because
they don't really know
what's going to work we've never
generated a vaccine
that's protective for coronaviruses so
we don't really know how to do it
there are all sorts of competing
technologies and pet ways of doing these
things
nobody knows which one's going to work
and which ones aren't so they've got to
spread things
maybe a little bit thinly but they've
got to back lots of horses
in order to get a winner
vaccine trials need people to test them
and the government's calling for
volunteers
it's worth remembering also less than
one in ten vaccines is successful
and even if a vaccine is found quickly
the race isn't over and there may well
be more effective vaccines to follow